mr. starker I don't feel so good okay so
normally today would have been overdue
Doctor Who except this friggin
spider-man thing happened and the if I
wasn't gonna bump that to later then I
was gonna have to wait till Friday on
this and I didn't want to wait that long
so here we go
the overdue doctor who's still happening
this week it's gonna be on Friday then
it goes back to Wednesday's soon mean
nothing else friggin blows up on me so
spider-man um looks like he's not going
to be in the MCU anymore now I say looks
like because the first thing I want to
say at the front end of this is that it
comes very close to failing to clear the
hurdle for what I consider rumors that I
try not to talk about which is that
there isn't really a whole big official
this is why this happens statement from
either of these studios that come out
and I tend to wait for that because we
live in an age right now where these
things happen and they get reported
right off the bat and sometimes that
means that stuff gets reported that's
just there's nothing behind it but other
times things get reported that yes it's
active it at the time but it's just a
cog in a bigger picture that's a big
part of why I don't ever do videos about
who's in talks for a role not until
they're signed because everyone seems to
forgotten
I remember when everybody was dead
certain that Joaquin Phoenix was gonna
be dr. strange you know what he wasn't
he was in talked but it didn't close and
it is distinctly possible that what
happened between Sony and Disney is just
a point in the negotiations negotiations
when they both walked away
maybe they'll both take a breather come
back find a middle ground maybe this
thing gets restored that is distinctly
possible so keep that in mind I'm still
gonna report on the situation as it
exists right now or at least at the time
I'm recording it this will go up the
next day hopefully nothing massively has
changed since then so let's recap what
even happened so the way spider-man Tom
Hollands spider-man who has now appeared
in Captain America Civil War spider-man
home
humming infinity war endgame and
spider-man far from home he is both in
these films produced by Sony but also
appearing in the Marvel films like a
Captain America Civil War and the
Avengers hums and the way that is able
to happen is Sony and Marvel have
reached a shared agreement now the
character of spider-man overall broadly
speaking is still owned by Marvel as a
character as a merchandising thing etc
however the movie rights the rights to
make films those currently reside with
Sony that's dating way back to before
Marvel even started producing its own
movies and well before Disney bought
them so Sony has the rights to make
spider-man movies and they had been for
a while but they really just ran into a
wall when it came to the amazing
spider-man the first one was decently
received the second one did not do
nearly as well as I thought it would and
at that point they struck a deal with
Marvel to bring them in and do something
jointly now the specifics of the deal
as it existed have come out a little bit
over time and here is the deal as it
existed at the time so I because I have
to cover what it was what they tried to
negotiate what each side won and why
they couldn't mean an agreement and then
I will talk about what does this mean
going forward so I got a lot of stuff to
cover and I probably gonna talk really
fast going through this so what Disney
had well what Sony got out of that deal
was Sony got Marvel to come in and take
creative control because Sony basically
threw up their hands and said look we're
not gonna sell this back to you because
it's too dang
but we are screwing it up please help us
now Disney even if they weren't gonna
gain the character back when I say
Disney Disney Marvel same thing at this
point when going forward in this video
so Disney had an incentive to actually
help them even if they didn't get the
character back because as I said outside
of the movies the character largely
primarily and fundamentally resides with
Marvel and Disney if Sony ever stops
making these things for long enough
there are clauses that will revert it
back so if Sony and it was getting to a
point where if Sun was gonna keep
spending money on these spider-man
movies they were gonna start losing
and it was almost getting to the point
where maybe it would have been better
for them just to sell it back but they
didn't want to do that but as I said
there isn't it just for Disney and
Marvel to help Sony out even if they
don't get the character back because
it's important that the IP not get
diminished that the brand did not go
down in value because the folks who you
license the movie rights to are running
it into the ground that's not good for
anybody so Sony got to bring in people
who knew how to do the characters and
we're having a lot better luck with
superhero movies and sony was to help
write the ship and it was in Disney and
marvel's interest to have that ship be
right because spider-man is arguably
Marvel's single biggest IP now as far as
financial conversation Disney actually
got very little all Disney got was 5%
off of what's called the first dollar
gross what that means is Disney took
home 5% of the box office takes not
after profits just straight-up whatever
the box office was Disney got 5% and now
that's not really law when you take into
account that Disney was not taking any
part of the ancillary to the back end
and they had absolutely no part in any
of the spider-man spin-off stuff which
so far has only amounted to venom but
there's a ton of stuff that Sony's
working on and has in the past wanted to
make into individual movies and Disney
had absolutely no part in that so that
original that original deal was actually
honestly a really sweet deal for Sony
because they got somebody to
rehabilitate the brand and they reap to
the vast majority of the rewards for
that now the other thing Disney got out
of that deal was they got to use
spider-man Peter Parker Tom Holland in
their own films in civil war and
infinity war an end game whereas before
that would not have been possible and
also as a result of that in homecoming
of far from home there got to be MCU
stuff there like Tony Stark and Nick
Fury and so on so that actually that
should kind of worked both ways into
everybody's benefit but honestly that
original deal sweet deal for Sony Disney
I want to go so hard to say that we're
doing a favor I don't want to distribute
that much you know sort of altruism to a
big mega corporation it was very
calculated but there was a reason they
were willing to extend that and it
have been pretty naive and wishful
thinking on Sony's part to think that
they were gonna be able to keep that
exact same deal but that appears to be
what they wanted sitting down to the
negotiating table to extend the deal out
for more films and more projects so
basically what it sounds like is Sony
wanted the same deal they already had
they just wanted to add more years onto
it
Disney they wanted a bit more now I'm
gonna throw some numbers out though
they're gonna make a lot of people just
shout ah greedy Disney ruined everything
but stick with me there's a little bit
of nuance to this now what Disney
apparently wanted was they wanted 50%
now that sounds like a huge jump that's
ten times more than they were getting
before but it wasn't just 50% of the
profits they actually want to do a
co-financing deal which means they were
also going to shoulder 50% of the cost
whereas before Sony was doing all of the
production cost Disney was handling the
creative him but Sony had control of the
pocketbook they had the power of the
purse which is why they were also
reaping the vast majority of the
financial rewards because they were
ultimately taking more of a risk from a
strictly financial point of view now
Disney wanted to say hey look we'll
split the cost 50/50 and will retain the
creative control but that also means
that we are gonna take 50% of the
profits on this now honestly I don't
think that's what broke the agreement if
I were to guess what might have broken
it what might have made Sony go oh no
was that it seems like Disney didn't
just want 50% of the main spider-man
franchise meaning the Tom Hollands led
films they wanted in on creative control
and also 50% split on the spin-offs as
well which again so far has only
resulted in venom but there's a lot more
in the works and I can absolutely see
why so nee would not want to give them
that because from their perspective
venom worked and was really successful
on the budget that it had now you can
debate over how good or not good you
thought that movie was but it did well
for them and they did that completely on
their own he didn't have to share
anything and developed it in-house so
the idea that Disney is basically going
oh those other things you're kind of
doing on your own we'd like in on that
too
now I'm sure their Disney
whatever had plans to like integrate all
the stuff more because since Sony did
venom completely on its own
that's why Tom Hollands spider-man
wasn't in it it wasn't part of the deal
so it had to be completely separate but
now Sony basically assumed
proof-of-concept that it is possible to
have a successful ancillary spider-man
film in which spider-man himself does
not appear in any way shape or form now
there have been initial reports with
that both sides just drew a hard line on
what they wanted and that was it
reports are coming in now or at least
statements from Tom Rothman who's the
current head over at Sony and that's
worth pointing out the guy at the head
of Sony right now is not the same person
who was at the head of Sony when that
original deal was struck so we are kind
of dealing with people who aren't just
going like oh yeah save these before
like no new guys new rules
so Tom Rothman has said that he was
prepared to give a little bit more but
that Disney was not willing to budge at
all from their position so according to
him and again that's only one side of it
at the time of recording Disney site is
not issued a statement about whether or
not they were willing to bend at all but
Tom Rothman is saying that they were
willing to meet halfway but Disney was
not and that means everybody just walked
away from the table now here's the thing
everyone's just kind of losing their
mind and going oh my god it's the end of
everything is awful it's everybody take
a breath calm down
I don't think it's as bad as everybody
seems to now believe it is and there's a
couple of things I want you to keep in
mind as far as keeping all this in
perspective now first of all I'm not
happy about this
I would prefer that this deal was still
in place but what I actually think about
and what this means I'm not that worked
up I'm a little sad but I'm not that
worked up cuz it's not so much as this
amazing thing is now broken it's more of
a case of Boy
it's impressive we got to have that at
all I'm kind of surprised it lasted this
long cuz honestly this deal was really
unique and made under very specific
circumstances that probably wouldn't
have replicated again and obviously
don't exist now because both because you
know Disney wasn't a person or it's like
no you can't have the same deal again
the circumstances are completely
different so I'm not shocked that they
weren't able to come to
agreement and honestly if you stop and
think about it if there is going to be a
divergence between the Sony spider-man
produced films and the MCU this is
probably the best point to do it at
because like endgame was a big finish
for pretty much that entire phase of
Marvel it really left nothing blatantly
set up for what would be the next step
including for spider-man so as far as
he's rolling the greater MCU films if
you leave it at endgame it feels I'm not
like there was nothing more to be told
but it feels pretty complete it's not
like oh we're missing his story and when
you look at the way that the MCU had
been woven in to homecoming and far from
home yes we are gonna lose that but I
also feel like where things had gotten
to by the end of the second film at by
the end of far from home I'm not sure
they need the Marvel connections anymore
obviously
Iron Man isn't part of the picture
anymore and well Nick Fury was fun the
movie by no means was a make or break on
that and that little franchise there
that Tom Holland led spider-man films
those have built up enough of their own
thing going on it doesn't really need
the MCU connections anymore it's also
worth pointing out that the director of
those films while not yet locked down is
currently in negotiations for at least
one if not two more and I do think as
far as that primary franchise goes that
the groundwork that they're on at this
point is solid enough and coupled with
the fact that Sony is not headed by the
same people who completely botched
amazing spider-man that puts me in a
position where I'm prepared to go okay
if they can retain the director and even
though they lose Kevin Feige if they can
retain the director and some of the
other creative people I think there's a
very good chance that they can deliver
at the very least a third film going on
from this that lends itself to just
building off of what came before and
still working and not suddenly falling
apart provided Sony doesn't do what it
is done historically we spider-man which
is to force or the insertion of all the
stuff that will lead to spin-offs and
again I'm not as doom and gloom about
that as I might have been a few years
ago because the people heading Sony were
not saying people who were doing that
over and over and over again not to say
the new people having Sony are perfect
they're making mistakes too
just look at what happened with men in
black international but they don't have
the tainted history with this specific
franchise and that for me is a reason
for not necessarily optimism but just
not doing gloom over it and I know some
people have also said out well I mean
Sony also did into the spiders and
that's like the best spider-man movie
ever and yes it is but I'm not prepared
to give them a super ton of credit on
the basis of that simply because well
Lord Miller
headed that and it's hard to know how
much credit to give to Lord Miller I
mean they didn't direct it but they were
the minds behind it and I've said
repeatedly Lord Miller's entire thing is
figuring out how to take ideas that
should never work and figuring out how
to make them work even on films that
they have not directed like a movie to
was great they didn't direct it Lego
Batman was great they didn't direct it
into the spider members was great they
didn't direct it but they were deeply
involved in figuring out the story and
the angle and the way to approach all of
these movies so I don't necessarily look
at into the spider verse and go oh that
means that they'll be able to just do
that well with the main spider-man like
no we're looking at completely different
creative teams heading up these
situations so that doesn't impact my
view either way I think the main thing
we need to watch out for at this point
assuming that you know both sides don't
come back to the table and just work
this thing out but if that doesn't
happen then it's basically just a matter
of time before Sony integrates
spider-man with all the spin-off stuff
they were working on which as a reminder
is a sequel to venom which now has a
director in Andy Serkis
they are working on a Morbius movie they
are working on a craven movie I think
the silver sable and black cat movie
fell apart but that was on the docket at
one point like there's a lot of stuff
that they can work on and they none of
that had been tied to spider-man before
because it wasn't part of their shared
deal with Marvel and Marvel didn't want
those spin-offs tied in they didn't want
these things that they had no control
over to be leeching off the MCU
but with all that in place I would be
surprised if they didn't start
integrating that in the other thing is
though how much longer they're even
gonna have Tom Holland now I'm found
slightly mixed things about whether he
has one or two more movies on his
contract
I'd heard before was that he only had
one movie left on his contract but in
some of the things it looks like he may
have negotiated at this point for a
fourth or maybe it was on there and we
didn't know about it it's not entirely
clear but unless he reappears contract
which that's a whole separate set of
negotiations but unless he does that
they get at least one maybe two movies
out of him and so in my mind that's the
big worry is if they think they're gonna
lose Tom Holland after a couple more
movies I'm worried that there is going
to be an instant and not just because
it's only just because that's the studio
mentality to milk everything that can
possibly get out of those times and as
long as they can resist the urge to do
that I think there aren't solid enough
footing so like I said I'm not happy
about this I'm not thrilled about it but
from a business standpoint I get it I
totally get why Sony would walk away
from this and say no we think we're on
solid enough ground that we can we can
take it from here and I also don't think
that automatically think that they're
going to screw it up which some people
seem to be assuming at this point again
different people heading the studios and
planning the direction for things
overall then there were at the time that
spider-man 3 happened or the in both
amazing spider-man movies happen so
again that's not so far as to say
benefit of the doubt I'm sure it'll be
fine
no I don't know that but I'm also not
automatically going ons doomed and
ruined I think enough of the groundwork
that Kevin Feige and his team put in to
help right this ship is there that we're
gonna get at least one more good movie
out of this before it all goes
completely pear-shaped and potentially
maybe even keep working after that
because maybe inside the spider-verse
isn't a fluke maybe it's not just down
to Lord and Miller I don't have
necessarily have the faith that that's
the case but it's the possibility and
I'm again not happy it's not good news
but it's not the disaster a lot of
people are saying at least not to my
eyes not how I see it
how much you want to bet that a lot of
what I said has now been negated
corrected or whatever between what I
shoot this and when I edit it put it up
we'll find out your thoughts on
spider-man no longer being part of the
MCU or whatever noon
is broken on it since I shot this darn
thing whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff to do
down there
like subscribe really big help if you
want to support me in this channel and
help make it better
there's the patreon that also helps me
cover my bills it's a huge help and
there is other stuff down there my
socials link to a book I wrote all that
sort of stuff check it out down below
click on links they'll take you places
or don't I don't know what happened to
my voice but at the end of the day
you're the council and I'm just running
the meetings until next time I don't
know this council is adjourned
punch-drunk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]